when you do Archer yeah it is such a fun
show to watch but it's also it's it's a
little dirty it's attached you know it
is animated but it's not for your
children it's a little dirty and for a
while I don't know if we're gonna do it
again we were doing these things called
Archer live where we were flying around
the country and selling tickets and
people were coming and we were reading
an episode of Archer live on stage and
we have audience participation and
everything and it was really fun and it
would get kind of blue little little
dirty little maturity little immature we
did one in Austin Texas and for the
first time we had two people signing on
either side of the stage Oh for the
hearing-impaired they did sign language
it was so nice so nice and we were doing
our show and saying all the dirty things
that we say and then we kind of were
noticing like oh they have to they have
to sign all these really dirty words and
we started trying to think of the
dirtiest things that we can say to see
what it looks like inside yeah we really
went off script and we just said it all
we we were excited to see what the sign
was for like a lady the lady part the
vagina
yeah but then think of another word for
vagina like a bad word like that that's
really can be very offensive yeah right
yes one syllable yeah yeah yeah one
syllable yeah okay so we learned that
you said that or someone said that so
many times
I mean honestly if we'd had a dollar for
every time we said it and we said this
is a small one of it and we said the
great big giant one of it and it's there
at you you're not telling what the sign
language was for that is ballots okay
all right all right okay is that here
that's it yeah but it's like a so this
is I think what you would do just for
the regular right you're like when it's
that word it's just an angrier yeah more
aggressive
[Laughter]
yeah hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography